est il nécessaire que les citoyens soit
informé de l'état de santé de leur
président dix jours après l annonce de
sa contamination coville 19 le président
américain sortant donald trump est
apparu plus pimpant que jamais à la
tribune du balcon de la maison blanche
face à une foule de partisans et ils
l'assurent tout va pour le mieux
tout d'abord je vais très bien je ne
sais pas pour vous comment vous allez
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
grâce à la puissance de l'esprit
américain plus que toute autre chose
la science et la médecine vont éradiquer
le virus chinois une fois pour toute
l'équipe médicale de donald trump se
montre désormais optimiste quant à son
état de santé
ce soir je suis heureux d'annoncer que
le président remplit tous les critères
des autorités sanitaires pour une
cessation en sécurité de l' isolement
le test que vite pcr de ce matin montre
au regard des normes actuellement
reconnus qui n'est plus considéré comme
risquant de transmettre le virus à
d'autres personnes
il n'y a plus d' indice de réplication
active du virus
la charge virale de donald trump diminue
à moins d'un mois de la présidentielle
les médias outre atlantique avait
pourtant commencé à s'inquiéter
plus encore les rumeurs les plus folles
s'était mise à paraître sur les réseaux
sociaux à propos de l'état de santé de
donald trump des tweets partager des
milliers de fois affirmé que les
démocrates pourraient avoir infecté
intentionnellement le président avec le
coronavirus au cours du débat avec joe
biden
d'autres écrivait sur facebook que le
président faisait peut-être semblant
d'avoir été contaminés la nouvelle avait
également déclenché les spéculations des
adeptes de la thèse conspirationniste
cannon qui colportent une croyance son
fondement selon laquelle donald trump
lutterait contre un réseau secret le
satanisme et nos fils se livrant au
trafic d'enfants à l'ère des réseaux
sociaux où chaque théorie aussi folle
soit elle peut être partagée sur la
toile difficile de savoir exactement ce
qu'il en est du coup qu'en est il en
france est bien chez nous le moins que
l'on puisse dire est que c'est motus et
bouche cousue lorsqu'il s'agit de la
santé des présidents de la république
le sujet reste stable malgré les
promesses réitérées des chefs de l'état
successifs de la vème république de
publier des bulletins de santé réguliers
la transparence n'a jamais été
totalement respecté
al'inverse des états unis où la
révélation des maladies dues
et dans quelle qu'en soit la nature est
une obligation les présidents français
entretiennent un rapport complexe avec
le secret médical la protection de la
vie privée et le droit à l'information
alors que le général de gaulle avait été
hospitalisée le 17 avril 1964 pour une
ablation de la prostate sans conséquence
le débat sur la santé des chefs d'état
est réellement apparu avec la mort de
georges pompidou le 2 avril 1974 à l'âge
de 62 ans ce dernier était atteint de la
maladie de waldenström une forme de
cancer du sang mais en dépit de signes
inquiétants de fatigue et surtout de la
dégradation de sa condition physique
depuis l'automne 1972
aucune information déclaration ou
communiqué n'avait été publié par
l'elysée sur la gravité de son état
seuls des indications y compris
d'origine médicale faisait état de
grippe à répétition lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 1974 valéry giscard
d'estaing alors âgé de 48 ans avait pris
l'engagement de publier deux bulletins
de santé par une promesse qu'il oubliera
bien vite après son élection en 1981
françois mitterrand qui avait alors 64
ans avait voulu se montrer exemplaire en
publiant un bulletin médical au
lendemain de son accession au pouvoir le
dit mais je me dois de rendre publiques
les informations que les français sont
en droit d'attendre de celui qu'ils ont
choisi pour assumer la plus hautes
charges de l'état
le problème essentiel est que les ennuis
de santé ne doivent pas être telle qu'il
puisse nuire à la fonction c'est ça la
morale qu'un responsable politique doit
respecter des paroles prometteuse qui
cachait en fait un véritable mensonge
d'état
le médecin personnel de françois
mitterrand claude gubler a avoué dans un
ouvrage paru en 2006 avoir falsifié tous
ses bulletins de santé
opéré le 11 septembre 1992 à l'hôpital
cochin françois mitterrand fut contraint
de reconnaître qu'il était atteint d'un
cancer de la prostate
il subira une nouvelle intervention le
18 juillet 1994 à la fin de son second
mandat
avant de décéder le 8 janvier 1996
idem pour jacques chirac et nicolas
sarkozy qui tous deux s'étaient engagés
à tenir les citoyens informés de leur
état de santé
pourtant ce n'est qu'à demi-mot que
l'élysée révélera les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux du premier elle
est malade vago agrémenté
une opération à la gorge du second
l'engagement solennel des chefs d'état
étaient pourtant logique comment faire
pleinement confiance à des hommes de
pouvoir censé guider la nation lorsque
des doutes persistent sur leur état de
santé